[Musique]
bonsoir
commençons par un chiffre en 2015
un sondage ipsos révélait que 31% des
femmes estimaient que leur départ un
congé maternité avait eu un impact sur
leur carrière
un impact négatif une femme sur trois
alors oui je sais s'il ya des jeunes
filles ou des jeunes femmes dans la
salle ce soir c'est pas très
encourageant a bien à quoi bon
poursuivre ses études ou faire ses
preuves dans son premier emploi puisque
manifestement pour un tiers d'entre vous
à un moment ou un autre il faudra
choisir entre le travail et les enfants
comment dans ces conditions pour jug et
carrière et maternité
cette question je me la suis posé et
reposé en 2008 à la naissance de mon
premier enfant
à ce moment là je me suis retrouvé au
centre d'un triangle que de nombreuses
femmes connaissent partagé entre ma vie
de femme ma nouvelle vie de mère et ma
vie professionnelle
alors évidemment ce triangle peut aussi
s'appliquer aux hommes qui eux aussi
deviennent pères à la naissance d'un
enfant
mais même si les choses s'améliorent
sans chef
merci messieurs les chiffres sont encore
là en 2016 selon l'observatoire des
inégalités
une femme passe encore deux fois plus de
temps que son conjoint par jour à
s'occuper des tâches domestiques et à
s'occuper des enfants
et en plus du soin quotidien accordée
aux enfants c'est aussi nous le plus
souvent
qui avant ce qu'on appelle la charge
mentale des enfants
qu'est ce que c'est la charge mentale un
exemple si je reprends le sondage dont
j'ai parlé précédemment
et bien quand il faut aller chercher un
enfant malade à l'école dans 61% des cas
fait maman qui répondent présentes ou
qui se débrouille pour trouver une
solution pour aller récupérer son enfant
malade
comment ne pas se sentir tiraillé entre
sa vie de mère et son envie légitime de
voir s'épanouir professionnellement
c'est bien sûr cette nouvelle relation
au travail qui s'installe à ce moment là
dans la vie d'une femme que je voudrais
faire porter mon propos ce soir en me
posant cette question et on vous la
posant aussi
et si malgré les chiffres et malgré les
oiseaux de mauvaise augure qui vous
prédisent la fin de votre carrière à
peine votre grossesse annoncée
et si la naissance d'un enfant était
l'opportunité d'une renaissance
professionnels pour ma part en 2008
je suis une collaboratrice impliqué dans
une entreprise du secteur automobile
j'aime mon travail et les opportunités
qu'ils m'apportent et puis voilà qu en
août 2008
je tiens dans mes bras mon premier né en
comptant les jours de congés j'avais
cumulé
et puis mon congé maternité je reviens
au travail en janvier 2009 soit 9 mois
plus tard sept mois plus tard parle et
c'est là le premier élément que je
voudrais partager avec vous ce soir
la naissance d'un enfant entraîne de
fait une rupture professionnelle dans la
vie d'une femme bien oui parce que même
si le congé paternité s'est démocratisée
jusqu'à présent c'est encore nous qui
accoucheront et c'est nous qui nous
éloignons de notre travail plus ou moins
longtemps selon
nos envies et surtout selon nos
possibilités
alors oui pendant cette période la vie
de l'entreprise continue des clients
n'attendent pas des postes se libèrent
auquel ne pouvons pas prétendre
et pourtant si nous envisagions ces
périodes de rupture professionnelle non
pas comme la mise au placard assuré mais
comme une opportunité une possibilité de
prise de recul
en effet le fait de s'éloigner au
quotidien comme ça de son nom
professionnelle pendant pendant ces
périodes de pause peuvent être
l'occasion pour vous de voir votre
travail avec des yeux neufs
peut-être même de repérer les
dysfonctionnements de revenir avec des
innovations mon manager de l'époque ne
s'y étaient pas trompés parce qu'il
m'avait demandé de réaliser un rapport
d'étonnement
à mon retour à mon travail et c'était
d'ailleurs dans ces conditions là que je
lui avais proposé une focus fication
notre reporting commercial
parce que pendant que j'étais en congé
de maternité avec mon bébé dans les bras
j'étais loin des chiffres et du
quotidien d'un coup je m'étais aperçu qu
en quelque sorte vous êtes deux fois le
même travail
si vous n'avez fesci bien les hommes on
peut la possibilité d'avoir ces périodes
de pause de prise de hauteur par rapport
à leur travail
alors mesdames capitaliser sur ces
périodes de rupture professionnelle
transformer les emprises de recul et
revenait avec des idées neuves pour le
bénéfice de toutes et de tous
en 2009
je reviens donc au travail je me sens
différente comme plus forte et c'est là
le deuxième point que je voulais
partager avec vous ce soir
l'historienne event libye leur le dit
très bien mettre au monde des enfants
n'est pas seulement un épanouissement
charnel
cela provoque aussi la maturation des
capacités y compris professionnelle
alors avec mes mots à moi ça reviendrait
à dire revenir la même en mieux
en effet avoir cru devenir folle favreau
sanglots inconsolable de morisson
pour ma part moi ça m'a armé pour faire
face aux réunions les plus difficiles et
que dire de ma capacité de travail
moi qui jusqu'à mes 30 ans mettait
toujours considéré comme une grosse
dormeuse je peux vous dire que dix ans
et trois enfants plus tard je peux finir
relativement tard un dossier et être
quasiment frêche le lendemain et puis on
découvre ce que c'est que l'efficacité
plus question de rester au bureau
jusqu'à 20h30 pour peaufiner un dossier
vous rentrez récupérer son enfant à la
crèche ou chez la nounou mais pas
seulement parce que nous aimons notre
travail mais nous voulons aussi assisté
aux premiers pas de notre enfant nous
voulons aussi être près de lui le soir
pour les devoirs
quels meilleurs boosters pour améliorer
sa gestion du temps que l' envie de
passer aussi du temps avec ses enfants
et qu'elle meilleurs boosters que ses
enfants pour oser proposer à son
employeur de travailler différemment de
rendre des réunions plus efficace par
exemple de mettre en place le
télétravail
bref à vous d'être force de proposition
ne revenez pas au travail avec
l'étiquette de celle qui a eu un enfant
revenez avec tout ce que vous êtes vous
la femme qui oui a eu un enfant mais qui
revient aussi plus forte
boosté par l'énergie que cet enfant lui
insuffle en un mot revenez vous en mieux
en 2011 nouvelle rupture professionnelle
j'attends mon deuxième enfant à cette
occasion je prend six mois de congé
parental et je change de poste
à mon retour pourtant j'avais commencé à
l'entendre cette phrase à il va falloir
songer à freiner son évolution
professionnelle quand même avec deux
enfants démarrent
cependant pour moi deux années
passionnantes où je découvre un nouveau
métier
je rencontre beaucoup de gens je voyage
beaucoup avec deux enfants en bas âge à
la maison pourquoi parce que j'ai un
mode de garde qui fonctionne et sur
lequel je peux me reposer
alors certains quand je quitte la maison
le matin je le fais avec une pointe de
culpabilité mais je le fais aussi
confiante et sereine
par rapport à mes enfants et c'est là la
troisième clé que je voudrais vous
livrer ce soir sur ce fameux équilibre
vie professionnelle vie personnelle
l'importance du mode de garde garde
partagée assistantes maternelles crèches
peu importe
une femme ne peut pas être concentré et
efficace dans son travail
si elle ne s'est pas ses enfants bien
gardé si elle ne sent pas ses enfants
bien gardé une renaissance
professionnelle passe par la mise en
place d'un mode de garde
serein en 2014 nouvelle rupture
professionnelle
j'attends mon troisième enfant et c'est
le début de mon enterrement
professionnels ah oui parce que à
l'annonce de cet heureux événement j'ai
dû avoir plusieurs fois ce type de
réaction alors tout d'abord non mais
attends c'est un accident
non parce que 3 ou faut aussi rapprocher
faut être un peu fou quand même tout de
suite suivi de cette phrase fait fameuse
phrase bon maintenant tu vas tu arrêter
travailler maintenant que tu as trois
enfants à la maison
oui bien sûr je me suis arrêté
quelques mois en congé parental parce
que je voulais profiter de ces moments
extra avec mes petits mais pas que cette
pause professionnelle fut aussi pour moi
l'occasion de faire le point sur les
aspirations et 2015 a été l'année de
toutes les audaces je quitte mon
entreprise je me forme au coaching jose
pousser des portes et je rencontre des
gens passionnants je développe mon
réseau j'écris un livre ça ressemble à
un enterrement professionnels non bien
sûr
bien au contraire qu'elle fécondité jeu
je vis là pleinement une renaissance
professionnels et pour cela j'ai
appliqué en fait les points dont je vous
ai parlé précédemment
premièrement la prise de recul comme je
vous le disais j'ai mis au point j'ai
mis à profit ces moments de pause
professionnelle pour faire le point sur
mes aspirations
deuxièmement la même en mieux
maman de trois enfants je me sens
épanoui poser expérimenté prête pour de
prendre de nouvelles responsabilités et
relever de nouveaux défis
troisièmement l'énergie ces trois petits
bouts mes enfants me pousse me donne
l'envié et le courage d'aller défricher
de nouveaux horizons alors oui bien sûr
il m'épuise comme tous les enfants je
crois mais c'est aussi en eux que je
puisse cette nouvelle énergie pour
avancer c'est eux qui me donne ce
courage quatrièmement la fécondité la
fécondité au sens large car pour moi la
naissance de mes enfants s'est
accompagnée d'une formidable ouverture
aux autres alors cela m'a permis de
développer mon réseau bien sûr mais
surtout surtout ça m'a permis d'élargir
mes horizons
cinquièmement je vous en ai parlé
le mode de garde qui fonctionne sur
lequel je peux me reposer et puis à mes
côtés
j'ai aussi le sixième point qui m'a
permis de vivre cette renaissance
professionnel ma renaissance
professionnel j'ai à mes côtés un
conjoint qui me soutient
inconditionnellement et qui me soutient
aussi au quotidien dans le partage des
tâches domestiques et dans l'éducation
de nos trois enfants alors pour cela
merci mon amour
en effet mesdames saviez vous que votre
carrière professionnelle ne dépend pas
que de vous elle dépend elle varie aussi
en fonction de la personnalité de votre
conjoint ce n'est pas moi qui le dit ce
sont deux chercheurs un homme une femme
deux américains et selon leur étude
plus votre conjoint est impliqué dans la
vie de famille plus votre salaire est
élevé eh oui et toujours selon brittany
salomon et joshua jackson donc ces
fameuses et américains plus votre
entente est bonne avec votre amoureux
plus vous vous sentez bien dans votre
job et plus vous grimpez rapidement les
échelons de la hiérarchie
alors bien sûr on a vu qu'il y avait
encore beaucoup de boulot à faire sur le
partage des tâches domestiques
s'il vous plaît messieurs mais c'est
bien là le dernier élément que je
voulais partager avec vous ce soir
appuyez vous sur votre moitié
je suis intimement persuadé que l'on ne
réussit pas seuls ou en tout cas pas
contre ou en dépit la personne avec
laquelle on partage sa vie mais bien
avec elle car finalement cette
renaissance professionnel est bien plus
qu'un simple projet professionnel
c'est un projet de vie et ce projet de
vie il faut la juste et sans cesse à
deux ensemble car je me doute bien que
cet équilibre va évoluer
quand mes enfants auront quinze ans ou
25 ans j'ai fait de longues études parce
que je voulais avoir un travail qui me
plaît j'aime vraiment travailler j'aime
développer des projets en équipe
j'aime atteindre des objectifs mais je
suis aussi cette mère qui prend plaisir
à voir grandir ses enfants et ses deux
éléments
loin de s'opposer me constitue
pleinement
il n'y a pas d'un côté la femme active
et de l'autre la main
il y à moi tout simplement avec toutes
ses formidables opportunités qui
s'ouvrent à moi et pour lesquelles des
générations de femmes se sont battues
alors pour terminer mon témoignage ce
soir je voudrais vous raconter une
histoire
c'est dans un village il ya un vieux
sage un petit garçon et le petit garçon
passe ses journées à poser des questions
aux vieux sage et le vieux sage a
toujours la réponse juste le petit
garçon il aimerait bien lui poser une
colle une fois au vieux sage à une
question auxquelles il ne saurait pas
répondre alors jours il a une idée il
attrape un petit oiseau et le prêt entre
ses mains il se dit je vais aller voir
le vieux sage et je vais lui poser cette
question est-ce que l'oiseau est mort ou
vivant entre mes mains
si le vieux sage me répond qu'il est
vivant j'écrase ray un peu mais - et
puis quick le petit oiseau sera mort et
s'il me répond qu'il est mort j'ouvrirai
mes mains et l'oiseau s'envolera tout
content de cette farce qui va faire au
vieux sage et s'approche et lui avec
l'oiseau dans les mains il lui pose
cette question est-ce que l'oiseau est
mort ou vivant entre mes mains
le vieux sage et réfléchie et puis lui
dit la réponse est dans tes mains
alors ce soir je voudrais vous dire la
même chose
mesdames messieurs votre reconnaissance
professionnelle elle est au creux de vos
mains
ne laissez personne vous dire le
contraire merci
[Applaudissements]